what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
so I'm recording this before I've even
uploaded Captain America Sam Wilson for
civil war 2 and I have no idea how
divisive that videos gonna be there's
gonna be one those either you love it or
you hate it
and it is I'm almost terrified to read
the comments because people have a
tendency to think emotionally instead of
rationally when it comes to like you
know deep-seated feelings and so because
of that I'm curious to see what
direction the comments section takes but
the idea here is that that seems or at
least that story seems to be as
politically charged as Nick Spencer
Gifts now a lot of them ages because
Nick Spitzer was pissed about having to
do civil war to you and maybe deciding
kind of Torpedo Civil War to to a degree
I'm not really sure but um what this
does or at least what Marvel now 2.0
with regards to Sam Wilson take back the
shield does is it kind of gives us about
4-1 shots and then it rolls into the
volume the official volume of take back
the shield at least as far as I can tell
that seems to be the case of course we
have one issue that focuses on misty 9
and other focuses on rage I think it is
we have one that focuses on demolition
man but this one really focuses on how
Steve Rogers is working behind the
scenes to basically make life hell for
Sam Wilson and it's kind of crazy here
because remember for those of the guys
were just now joining us with regards to
Marvel now to point out one of the big
changes that was made to Steve Rogers
was that we're prior to the events with
Secret Wars he had lost his Super
Soldier Serum P was aged to the point
that he did basically just kind of
became the director of shield and then
going into all-new all-different marvel
a lot of those standards were maintained
during the events of Avengers stand off
when the Cosmic Cube was basically
restored to the moral landscape the Red
Skull used the Cosmic Cube to to return
Captain America back to his youth but
then also changes history so that
instead of being you know a super
soldier that fought on behalf of America
the Red Skull altered reality so that
his history was now the fact that he was
basically a Hydra agent and that's how
Nick Spencer really roll the whole Hydra
story into Captain America it was cool
it was super cool like that I can never
get past that moment where he just says
hail Hydra it was it was so awesome to
see but the Sam Wilson stories really
take Captain America from the other
direction in the sense that where Steve
Rogers was very you know focus on saving
the world you know the you know the
leader of the Earth's Mightiest Avengers
Sam Wilson is very grounded
in terms of how he conducts himself as
Captain America focuses on a lot of
small things now what this has done is
draw the ire of a lot of very powerful
people because the ground-level
superhero antics were usually left to
like spider-man they were left to
daredevil to the Punisher the Punisher
was usually the guy that took out you
know corrupt politicians Sam Wilson
focusing on a lot of these ground-level
issues like governmental corruption
means that these things are being
brought into the light more so than they
ever were before and so Sam Wilson has
basically kind of become this thorn in
the side of the corrupt politicians and
corrupt members of corporations and so
on but one of the guys who is most
outspoken was a guy by the name of Tom
Harold now keep in mind during civil war
- Tom Harold was a senator from Texas
they had basically moved in the
direction of pushing the America so to
say you know these cops that were very
totalitarian in nature there were a lot
of issues of them profiling so on and so
forth but what happens here is while
he's in the middle of a speech talking
to campaign donors the entire thing is
interrupted by the arrival of ultimatum
and flag Smasher now this again is Nick
Spencer drawing on the mark Grunwald era
of Captain America which I don't know if
you guys notice but but Greenwald had a
huge contributing hand to the Captain
America mythos because some of the most
notable members of his rogues gallery it
came out of out of his run you know came
out of a of Grunwald's rona so again
this really seems to be an expense or
you know kind of paying homage which is
actually good to see because I think
that a lot of instances writers are so
keen on you know making their own take
on a character that not a lot of praise
is given to contributions of previous
writers and so it's really cool to see
that that you know things are going in
this direction but again Sam Wilson
still also truss struggling with this
whole idea of whether or not he's
accepted someone and so forth but of
course you know him being here comes at
the behest of Sharon Carter who has you
know summoned him on behalf of shield as
well as Steve Rogers and Rick Jones now
again Rick Jones is not really a bomb in
all-new all-different marvel instead he
initially showed up as a guy who was
just operating behind the scenes the
Whisperer who is more or less like this
this Marvel allegory to WikiLeaks he was
basically going through he was you know
making these huge information dumps
that's how the world learned that shield
was basically creating cosmic cubes in
the first place you know but the idea is
that Rick Jones was essentially saved
from his sentence by Sam Wilson and he
basically kind of operates behind the
scene as a member of shield is this idea
that as long as Rick Jones does what
he's told to do his sickness will
basically be commuted but again we also
have the arrival of Steve Rogers now
with regards to Sam Wilson being here
it's just
other instance that everybody hates him
you know the the general public here in
the story that s inexpensive writes it
it's essentially a reflection of the
naysayers from from from Sam Wilson's
character that are like no we want Steve
Rogers we don't want Sam Wilson and so
when Steve Rogers shows now people are
like yeah it's Steve Rogers this is
amazing this is awesome now of course
once Steven Sam actually get into the
room where all the campaign donors and
where Tom Harrell is being cut flag
Smasher actually creates a really
interesting scenario and I'm curious on
what your all's I want a response to be
though on this what I want to know what
your also thought is here the flag
Smasher has historically been this B or
C list level character he was always a
minor villain that would just pop up
from time to time and he would fight
people but he was an anarchist he was a
guy that alongside ultimatum the goal
was to basically just bring the
governments of the world toppling down
and just let Anarchy reign supreme now
the irony of all this is that people
inherently flocked to security like a
multi multitude of people really most
people flock towards the idea of
security they want to know that what's
here today is going to be here tomorrow
it's just it's human nature it's on a
byproduct of like the modern age it's
just always been that way that's why
ever since there's been more than five
people in a room somebody was in charge
because people always want to know that
what it really hits the fan that
somebody will be able to guide them
towards you know a safer direction the
reason I say this is so ironic is
because let's say that like the country
were to enter a state of Anarchy where
the government came crashing down all
you would have is a rise of petty
strongmen you would have no Charmin you
would have people who were warlords and
people would flock to them they would
sacrifice some measure of freedom for
their own security it's just kind of how
people are but the idea here is a flag
Smasher basically says we're all
fighting for the same cause here you
know we're fighting for the same thing I
want Anarchy I want these corrupt
politicians to come crashing down you
know I want these corrupt businesses to
come crashing down you basically want
the same thing now the difference here
of course is a flag Spencer wants to
take it a step further
but the question he proposes here is
really interesting this is why I say I
want to know what your all stance is on
this what flag Smasher basically does is
he offers the scenario if you could take
out a person who had made your life hell
would you do it now the reason why he
proposes this is to really kind of get
his same Wilson but he's talking about
Tom Harold he's like look Tom Harold is
one of the most outspoken people when it
comes to the idea that Sam Wilson is not
Captain America well he hasn't served in
the military he's not a real American
because he doesn't have the same kind of
values that Steve Rogers has he doesn't
share our views that kind of thing if
Sam Wilson could do it would he kill Tom
Harold and that's a question I'm posing
to you guys so there was someone out
there who was just making your life
absolute hell you know who was
questioning you at every turn every step
of the way they were constantly haunting
your footsteps they were there to say
hey you know you know don't do that do
this you know you're not really you know
you're not great you're not you know
would you take them out and if you would
then where does a line-drawing stop at
what point do you get rid of the guy
like it what point do you transition
from getting rid of the guy that's
making your life hell to getting rid of
the guy who's just kind of outspoken it
creates some really weird dichotomies
here and it really kind of you know
gives us this scenario where things just
progressively fall downhill but even
then when flag smash is proposing the
idea of anarchy isn't necessarily that
bad now I don't mean to say that anarchy
end of itself is inherently good in the
sense that you know lawlessness is the
way to go I mean it would create
absolute pandemonium but what it does is
it basically creates a circumstance
where people can start over it gives
people the chance to really get society
the chance to do things all over again
it also removes the idea of anonymity
and it introduces accountability for
example there was a really good episode
called hated in the nation from the show
black mirror I don't have you guys watch
now but it's like a modern-day Twilight
Zone but the idea was that there was
this campaign on social media basically
Twitter and it was people who were like
this person needs to die and that person
needs to die and it was kind of this
system where individuals would go out
there and they would voice their own
opinions but they would remain anonymous
and so the concept of the the gist of
the episode was that there was
essentially this huge outbreak out all
of these technologically advanced B's or
something like that but they were
basically assigned to track down not the
individuals who were going to be killed
but the individuals who are using
anonymity to say who should be killed
and so you know anarchie in and of
itself creates this is this kind of
fresh moment this restart word you know
it presses this huge button and says now
there is no more invisibility now
everybody is held accountable and people
basically get to kind of start from
there the irony of all this the way that
expen sir is is drawing it is that flag
smasher himself is relying on anonymity
in the sense that we basically have him
saying there are bombs that are placed
all around the country in different
locations and these locations are not
you know highly populated areas there's
structural areas they're designed for
the purpose of taking individual things
down now this is really mixed prints are
kind of drawing on the Fight Club
concept in the sense that with regards
to Fight Club you know the grand
of detonating these bombs was to
basically take out the entire credit
system so that everybody started at zero
it really seems to be the same instance
here in the sense of flag Smasher is
saying look the first step to
introducing an anarchist state is to
remove all methods of profiling to
basically eliminate the standards that
people use to differentiate themselves
from other people to say I am better
than that person because and so what he
does is he says the first we're gonna
take out is the no-fly list because it's
designed to profile people and decide
who can and cannot fly the danger of all
this is that there are people on that
list that should not that should be on
there that are dangerous people are so
again it's really flag smashing account
you know starting to starting to fail to
see the point and while Rick Jones tries
to go through and basically prevent each
of these bombs from detonating and he's
largely successful in the end we also
have an actual bomb that's been planted
there by flag smasher and the location
of Steve Rogers Sam Wilson that it does
detonate and it really just kind of
descends into conflict here now under
normal circumstances I would just say
this is unnecessary this doesn't matter
it's really pointless but in fact it's
anything but pointless this is wildly
important the reason why is because of
how Sam Wilson's moving how Steve Rogers
is fighting the fact that they're
basically you know they're teaming up
and they're working together but I want
you to keep this moment in the back of
your head because at the end of this
comic Nick Spencer is gonna drop a
bombshell which is gonna be it's gonna
be crazy but essentially all these bombs
that have been activated or at least
that are set to go off by flag smasher
they basically decrypt the launch codes
for a nuclear missiles these these data
bombs or these really you know virus
pawns as you want to call them a decrypt
launch codes kind of send them out there
to the world's to anybody can set them
off they want to you know the idea is
that these are all essentially stopped
and so in and really in a panic flash
master says okay fine
if the bomb that was tied to Senator Tom
Harold is not going to detonate then
I'll just shoot him now of course the
Steve Rogers says hey Sam Wilson take
care of that Sam Wilson throws the
shield any misses he misses flag Smasher
and flag smasher shoots
senator Tom Harold now the reason why I
say this is so cool is because this is
really simple so looking around and
saying well things are just gonna get
worse now because not only do people
look at him and say you just not even
Captain America like sure you're a hero
sure you got the shield but you're not
really Captain America now they can pin
failure on his chest they can say you
got a senator killed because you're not
Captain America see you're not Steve
Rogers Steve Rogers would have hit flag
Smasher Steve Rogers would have knocked
that gun out of his hand but you're not
Steve Rogers now what we do from here is
we transition to a Hydra base with
Steve Rogers meeting up with dr. Erik
Selvig because people want dr. Erik
Selvig is kind of his man behind the
scenes but Sal vague we would normally
kind of dismiss it's like well he's just
a guy that's here the way that makes
Spencer really draws him out and again I
have this this discussion in my Captain
America Steve Rogers video but the way
that an expression describes him is if
Selvig is rural Salvage probably better
than almost anybody else out there in
the Marvel Universe because he's the one
that figured out that Ulysses powers are
not 100% perfect that inhuman who said
he could see the future during the
events of civil war that sometimes he's
wrong he's seeing alternate realities
he's the one that was kind of giving
Captain America or give him Steve Rogers
the information he needed to basically
work against the superhero community but
when Salvage says how is it that you
know why isn't the Sam Wilson missed
Steve Rogers basically says I know that
she'll I've been using it for half a
lifetime I know exactly how to stand and
hit my target
Sam Wilson doesn't and so what had
happened was when they were fighting
Steve Rogers was basically kind of
maneuvering Sam Wilson into position so
that he knew when Sam Wilson threw the
shield that he would miss Steve Rogers
made sure that Sam Wilson miss flag
Smasher and Tom Harrell was killed not
only that that's not flag Smasher that's
a life model decoy that was sent out by
Steve Rogers Steve Rogers is responsible
for all of this and the reason why he
engineered it is because Tom Harold was
at was basically a loose in remember Tom
Harold
Harry Hauser and all Kaine were the ones
who were present during the events of
Sam Wilson Civil War 2 when US agent
John Walker was brought in by Steve
Rogers to go out and fight Sam Wilson
and to basically take his shield away
and so what Steve Rogers says is this is
going to make things even harder for Sam
Wilson not only that again keep in mind
because Steve Rogers is a Hydra agent he
knows that trying to take on the United
States as a unified country will never
work the best way to do it is to
basically create rifts in the country to
create racial risk political risks
things that will force people or drive
people to be in a situation where they
will say that person's not like me
because and I don't want to have
anything to do with him to basically
create these differences and so a
country divided makes it easier for
Steve Rogers to more or less implement
his plan and eventually conquer the
United States so again this this is what
I say Nick Spencer is run is so good the
political stuff gets really preachy in
it and it does kind of get a little
annoying after a while
it discrete are really strong story for
Sam Wilson but in all honesty I'm really
interested in like what's
Rogers is doing behind the see this one
I love Captain America Steve Rogers so
much it's some of the best storytelling
with Steve Rogers character really since
like Ed Brubaker you know every Breakers
vol.5 when Bucky Barnes came back but
Steve Rogers is a Hydra agent I think
it's one of the greatest things to ever
happen to his character because it
creates some incredible storytelling but
I didn't even if you guys are new here
to come let's explain make sure you guys
to the sub button to become part of the
rod for if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]